Transcription: Leela Kamst
Relecteur: eric vautier
Le niveau des océans a augmenté
d’environ 20 cm depuis 1900.
Le rythme de cette hausse a triplé
ces dix dernières années,
sous l’influence grandissante
de la fonte des glaciers.
En 2021, le GIEC,
comprenez le Groupe inter-gouvernemental
sur l’évolution du climat,
estime que cette hausse
pourrait gagner un mètre
d’ici 2100.
Dans le pire des scénarios,
la montée des eaux pourrait atteindre
2 mètres en moins de trois générations.
Dans ce contexte, nous,
habitants insulaires du Pacifique,
nous élevons nos voix
pour chanter l’urgence d’agir,
pour faire revivre les liens
entre les Hommes et la nature.
Depuis 2014, notre chorale,
qui s’appelle VOCAL,
part à la rencontre des anciens
pour rassembler les chants et les contes.
Notre quête consiste à recueillir, dans
le respect, le patrimoine oral calédonien.
Notre chef de chœur
sait trouver l’inspiration
pour traduire ces récits
en musiques et en chants polyphoniques.
A présent, nous allons vous chanter
l’histoire du Cewen,
la tortue en langue vernaculaire kanak
de l’île de Maré, en Nengone.
Voix d’homme : Sur une île en danger
habitent des animaux marins
et des animaux terrestres.
Ils remarquent la montée
des eaux sur leur île.
Le changement climatique s’accélère,
ils décident d’en discuter.
Il faut choisir trois d’entre eux
pour aller chercher un pays d’exil.
Les trois animaux choisis furent
le héron, le tricot rayé et la tortue.
Le héron s’envole
et dit à ses deux compagnons :
« Je serai le premier
à trouver un pays ! »
Mais en cours de route, fatigué,
il rebrousse chemin.
Le tricot rayé, lui,
oublie sa mission en retrouvant des amis.
De son côté la tortue nage,
suivant le courant marin.
Elle entend le chant des pluviers fauves.
« Oh ! Je crois être près d’un pays,
mais je ne l’aperçois pas encore.
Dès que je serai trop fatiguée,
je me laisserai emporter. »
Elle s’endormit et à son réveil,
le lendemain matin,
elle était échouée sur une autre île.
Femme 1 : Je suis cette plage
de la côte ouest, érodée par la mer.
Femme 2 : Je suis le pêcheur
qui vit au rythme des marées.
Homme 1: Bientôt, le palétuvier ne fera
plus barrage à la force des vagues.
Femme 3 : Nouméa, je suis une plage du sud
soufflée par les cyclones.
Femme 4 : Je suis une tortue,
perturbée par la réduction des rivages.
Homme 2 : Lifou, je ne reconnais plus la
plage de sable blanc qui m’a vu grandir.
Homme 3 : Nouvelle Calédonie,
bientôt la montée des océans
nous obligera à trouver
une nouvelle terre d’exil.
(Applaudissements)